all right and we're live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode 50 thank you
guys for tuning in on the inner circle
network we do appreciate everybody for
stopping on by give us one second we're
gonna be sharing out this link so you
guys can check us out live as we kind of
see what's gonna happen here and give
one of our guys just a second but before
we get started in here we'll do some of
our intros introducing the king of
shallow the lord of the premium
experience the master of t torches King
I understand you're trying to get used
them and he knows I go glasses you know
I'm very positive I spit out the pop
Alex Rodriguez before me he didn't let
Alex Rodriguez set it up give me a gift
you know everybody else on base so I can
bring anybody home but hey check this
out people see the reason why I go last
is because of the boxing and stuff like
that wasn't any good boxing this week
normally in MMA and boxing they start to
pick up in the next coming months and
you say the March and so on next week we
have a good fight coming up but I wanted
to touch on the me bows normally bows
was coming they look fantastic I know
Brad will love that brass step your me
ball game up uh-huh
I'm watching you out here also um movies
um I see a lot of people talking with
black panther and you know talking about
pride and stuff like that and all right
that's just cute guys uh but the bottom
line is and not the you know be a braces
but he's not the only black superhero or
the first black superhero that has been
successful don't forget Wesley Snipes
and let's not forget spawn come on guys
now I understand you saying is a whole
black cast
you know I feel that black director but
let's not forget that we do have other
genres where you know that is prevalent
all right so everybody go out get your
tickets I'm going out and getting my
tickets and stuff like that I want to
see pitches posted tweet it out send it
back and forth let's play with it let's
have some fun with it um also I saw this
um show on Netflix didn't did any of
y'all see the show on Netflix the the
Cobra feel paradox did you see that I
have not seen it yet man watch the
Yankees first okay I haven't I can't get
back the hour and 25 minutes of my life
it was actually it was actually worse
than it was a slam dunk actually
somebody gave him a layup see the first
Cloverfield was kind of a weird bag it
was like it was weird because you know
the camcorder thing and on us on a feet
in New York City in you you're looking
at it it's like how is the monster oh my
god it was weird the second one was kind
of better because and it was based on
like that like the paranoid people feel
when they don't know what the hell is
going on some people go to yeah III
honestly say out of all three movies
please be number two mm-hmm this third
one tried to be life remember that movie
did you see the movie life did you see
that one that one in space the one he
was trying to like set up with the venom
venom yeah okay they tried something
like that and failed miserably that is
the most sleep-inducing think that I can
oh my god I fought through it I had to
take actually some 5-hour energy just to
get through an hour 25 minutes of it oh
that's that's not something I would
reckon
I'm sorry for going into surprise
awesome I just watch I want you to waste
your time to please see it and then and
get me and please feel free to get out
me black King David your foolish stupid
it's really good I loved it you're not
gonna say that you're not gonna stay
there you got some people talking about
that Monster Hunter like it's got and I
heard a lot of it last night I was just
sitting here holding back two chunks
I'm coming out of my mouth but shout out
the hip-hop game where I gotta watch
that video I heard that you went in on
the game thank you for keeping it real
my brother set that up to my man Lord
sorry let's go anchor right Lord saw the
sovereign of the singleplayer the keeper
of the ancient receipts Lord saw how you
doing tonight doing fantastic well I
actually could be doing better I'm a
little under the weather I since
yesterday morning that fools been trying
to kick down my door and it's hovering
right now it's hovering so I might be
under the table by the time this is over
I'm trying to stay afloat but otherwise
doing pretty good but yeah so there
wasn't much in the way of boxing last
night but there was UFC this Oh tell me
tell me
yeah UFC 221 and in Perth Australia not
the most honestly you could have you
could have had a fight night for this
you know you didn't even pay for this
you know the pay-per-view cars sometimes
as you know you gotta let the
up-and-comers get this shine you know
there was a lot of a lot of jiggly guts
you know like what but that's it they
were there was a lotta there was a lot
of good action so people getting
stretched and flushed out you know it's
always fun to see so it was it was good
action not necessarily super super
top-tier performers but let me talk
about a few of the the big matches right
so we had this kid man versus this kid
jingling fantastic fight both of these
guys have chins of granite um Matthews
called Jing Liang and a guillotine choke
that was supposed to put would put
anyone out
and Gimli and proceeded to perform the
most egregious foul I have ever seen in
MMA stick his fingers into Matthews eyes
as the ref is watching this and the ref
simply says take your fingers out of his
eyes and don't do that again I'm taking
away a point the man saved himself from
tapping out there's no question he was
tapping out and what he did what he did
to poke to the eyes and the ref just
gave him a slap on the wrist he should
have been disqualified right then in
there that said the cutoff to the newer
Flair when I saw it but hey but but both
guys have great Qin's great boxing so I
mean I guess you know they were wanted
people to see the full-on fight because
I think that was the first round we got
it
caught him in the guillotine all right
so after that yeah this is the fight of
the guts
this guy named - - Mara who's 9 is cold
against some other guy that just looked
like he did not belong there and fever -
smoked him this guy looks like a young
Mark Hunt um so I guess it was
appropriate that before he fought on
this card he stretched this guy out I
mean well he did stretch Ahmad they had
to stop the fight because it was just
too much he was just getting battered
alright so then now we move on to the
actual Mark Hunt fight martin hunt
makes his way back to the ring after i
thought he had basically retired it
makes his way back to the Octagon
against blades this kid blades stood
toe-to-toe with um the guy who just
fought steep a I forget his name I'm not
forgetting his name now anyone about so
for whatever reason I'm forgetting it's
over regard all right Francis and gone
with Francis and gonna so he took every
shot and gone oh hey deployed and this
guy has hard hands as well um they
stopped the fight he lost that fight
song download he stopped it because he
didn't want to quit but his eyes were
like swollen so this guy can give a
punch and take a punch
so basically mark on
caught him with a few have you know mark
on this is out to knock you out with
every punch that he yeah he caught this
kid with a lot of fire and the kid was
wobbled and he just held his ground took
it and then decided you know what I
don't want to do this anymore and just
proceeded to take mark mark hunt down
every time that he had the opportunity
at that for Mark Hunt what did you get
him on the ground if you can keep them
there if you're big enough to keep him
on the ground you can beat him pretty
handily so he wanted unanimous decision
over Mark Hunt in that regard but the
kid seems like he's a big-time contender
in the heavyweight division moving
forward and now we move on to the main
event
Yoel Romero vs. Luke Rockhold which was
supposed to be for the end I wanted to
see that gram I wanted to see that I
knew I wanted to see their yeah sorry
though it's for the interim time because
Robert Whittaker is hurt so I guess he's
gonna be out long enough that they feel
they need an interim champion to fill
out the time that he's gonna be out
thing was Romero does not make weight
like Romero is a career wrestler in my
opinion making weight is not not making
weight is not an option like it's I
don't care they said that he had he had
a short training camp he took the fight
on fairly short notice you know what you
got to make weight man especially you've
been waiting so much other your
professional make weight here three
pounds overweight he was three this is
that this is not weight that you can
burn off in 15 minutes in a sauna this
is not weight there and dropped by
taking a dump like you can't it's three
rounds over lot so he knew full well he
was not gonna make weight he goes in
there it was a good tactical fight until
he finally caught rock hold with a left
and smooth him out and then he and he
hit him with another left one he was
underground and that was the fight so he
knocks you all riled up and then he gets
in his face and talk smack me but I mean
dude you talk smack but you didn't make
weight like you know got it so
technically what did they kill him they
did they give him a no contest or no go
with it
no this happened in the way it was
yesterday so they agree that they were
still gonna fight I'm sure Rockhold was
compensated in some way shape or form
Rockhold because run home won at the
church yeah so he got I guess he got
some monetary compensation in addition
to if he had won the fight he would have
won the interim bail just Romero
wouldn't have been right a win no matter
what so you know so Romero considering
the performance he probably still gets
the shot at Whittaker when Whittaker
comes back so he's just not without a
belt so the build is up in the air at
this point all right that was my main
concern
yeah you gotta make one professional
dudes there that's disgusting
yes well next week we have more UFC and
we definitely have some more boxes yes
we do we do um shout-out on the merch
stuff um the site is not go live next
week don't worry I'm hot on that um I
actually was going to because I had a
couple of boxes when I um had the
initial runs of the shirts and I
actually have four more large shirts
only all right hit me in the DM on
Twitter you know you follow us you
should know hit me on the damn into
Twitter and give me that information so
I can give you the information on the
price of the shirts and get that out to
you quickly as possible shout-out to the
other four people that got t-shirts to
people you know want to remain a little
bit nameless you know type of thing and
I understand that because they with
other podcasts and they don't want you
know their privacy but then you know
it's two great listeners and people that
I play with actually I picked up their
shirts and they posted it on Twitter and
they love what they got and I appreciate
it also understand that you will have
that ten percent on cue ten percent off
coupon on all future purchases going
forward when I'm in colorways we're
gonna have themed events it additions
like tax and III a lot of stuff is
coming forth so
don't worry you guys will have all that
information in the next week for sure
all right let's do it
anchor did we put you to sleep with our
UFC talk the boss the door the door I'm
not used to five casting this early for
me it's always moving at a slow pace too
cos at night y'all on some laid-back
coin yet stuff like right here we are
some expresso early day expresso let's
get it let's pop let's go right so uh
we're gonna mix things up a little bit
differently wanted to talk about last
week's poll results or for the iron
Lords episode 49 we had a very
interesting result here so the question
for last week was with the recent
speculation of Microsoft looking to
acquire pub Gea and valve which rumored
acquisition would be the best for
Microsoft's vision and with actually in
last place with only 18 percent of the
vote EA integrate to game pass and move
that all that in there so and actually
in a close second or close segment third
and third place actually valve merged
with a PC space and actually right after
that as all of them
hashtag Skynet yeah number one with 33%
of the vote pub G secure and exclusive
so so question for the group here what
are you guys thoughts on this level you
King well I'm with the sky be honest
with you I honestly think this III
you're going to hear a serious rumblings
well you're not gonna hear serious and
Romans gonna get serious announcements
because we heard the rumblings right
silent they were a leaky fault
said a second ago then all of a sudden
quiet
I I believe that they you know just
wanted to whet your palate to let you
know you're listening games and stuff is
coming and by III with a big
announcement should be said on stage
well you want to floor people and let
people know that we are in it to win it
I believe then that is gonna be set
mm-hmm and I believe it's all three pop
G is easy with all three there
I don't think makes us get there of that
much money all right what's your
thoughts on the stuff like I said last
week I think pop G is is the easy one
right but I mean to me yeah you picked
them up you picked them up because you
already seen the success they've had of
the console there's no reason not to
have that game exclusive to you
especially if you have some sort of
roadmap for what you want to do with
that game in the future what maps do you
want to add how do you want to expand on
the game if you want to use them for
other types of games as well so yeah I
mean definitely securing a studio that
can give you more exclusives absolutely
fantastic to me though the big one is
valve think I think valve is the
services that valve provides the IP that
they already have that it's kind of been
dormant for a long time for Microsoft to
pick up valve and in turn steam that
would make them a juggernaut then at
that point if you do have pub G as well
you do what up G what you did with with
Minecraft like when they picked up mo
yang people who are like what what's
gonna happen with Minecraft on all these
other platforms and we're like now
they're gonna pull it you know they're
gonna pull it and there were like no
this who wasn't money to be made there
know so I would not be surprised if they
did something like that and you take pub
G you only pump GE but you're like hey
yeah we're putting on punky on
PlayStation you're gonna pay us to put
pugsy on PlayStation
we're gonna give you a version on the
Swiss we're gonna pay us to put it on
the switch it makes the most sense for
what I think they're trying to do way
down the line which is you know an Xbox
service whatever that may be so I don't
speak up G if they purchase protein
puppies going to them now III see if
they
they work it out with valve which I
honestly believe they will I believe
that is the big banger that's gonna
Microsoft or right and and and really
just hit it where it hurts you know
because a lot of PC gamers will fall
over all over the floor with that that
will really kill people
EA I don't know I could see them
integrating that the EA access to the
game pass I don't know what's the
numbers is the game pass most successful
then access more people's talking about
it you know I don't I don't know I see
that because they need those exclusives
and then you got the games but then you
can also keep your multi and get the DLC
and everything here furs I don't know I
actually see all of it maybe I'm a super
fan I'm a fool my perspective on the
whole thing I don't think they're gonna
buy a valve at least in terms of steam I
think what would sooner happen is they
would buy valve studios mm-hm and say oh
you got all these IPS you're not using
why while we just buy the game developer
Souter since you're clearly not making
anything yeah I figured out that way we
will take out those games and we'll put
them on Xbox and put it will keep them
on PC too but like okay maybe they spin
off steam do its own company and the
Gabe Newell just keeps doing this thing
keeps getting this money and I'll let
him have his own deal but that's really
more for the exclusive front but on the
other side I think of it as pub she's
also the easiest one but that's also not
really worthy of an e3 announcement it's
not that kind of writing unless unless
it was kind of like okay like where
we're gonna go and we're gonna go on e3
and announce here's a new map or here's
the official release date basically some
DLC a little bit here a little bit there
and then right afterwards say by the way
it's a never coming to any other
platform other than PC and Xbox but it
has to happen before it hits PlayStation
as well as its PlayStation you're the
same situation as Minecraft where with
Minecraft the only reason they kept that
game on PlayStation was because it was
already
out on PlayStation and that would look
worse for you to take it away true true
and I just think I mean the money
matters though man like you you knew the
amount of money you would be cutting
yourself off from and again like I said
it depends on what their vision is for
the future of Xbox has a brand if they
see themselves being everywhere I don't
see you know it's gotta start at some
point right so yeah I just I don't see
why just why that wouldn't matter moving
forward if that's what their vision is
again everything that they show them
with the gamepad stuff and whatnot it
that's what it leads me to believe um
could it could very well be something
completely different you know but uh I
don't know it's gonna be interesting
it's gonna be really interesting and
next couple years to see what they do
how they expand came past more as we see
kind of a clearer look at what their
actual vision is because we get little
snippets you know they give us little
snippets free now and again but there's
nothing there's not this still isn't a
clear concise this is our goal and
they're not gonna tell us that until you
know yeah they're ready to show it all
off it's slightly all behind closed
doors too and they read not good yeah I
can't tell us anything till the day of
yeah yeah but yeah so um I guess we'll
start getting some of the topics for the
evening I will pose the poll question at
the end for next week so let's start off
with Saab what is uh what do you bring
to the table this week oh so to the
table arm this week I'm having my
fireside about the greatest games of all
time
Shadow of the Colossus uh every now and
again I like to dive deep into these
games that I played in the past and just
talk play recently and just talk about
you know what my feelings are on the
game what not um how the classes is
special because it's one of the last
games on ps2 that mattered to me before
you know making them move on to the 360
tether classes came out maybe weeks
before the 360 launched and I mean Oh
King knows all of us was just looking
forward at that point so we weren't
really err at that point we're kind of
really ingrained in the Xbox ecosystem
well so if we weren't really paying too
much attention to ps2 games but the talk
around this game was such that I had to
pay attention I said you know what this
this is wait as a second game I loved
Iko Iko was one of those games that we
all played early on in the ps2 s
lifecycle so everything I heard around
this game led me to say you know what I
need to pick this up regardless of how
invested I am in ps2 at this point and
what I found was a a game that on it
from a technical perspective on the ps2
hardware which should have been
impossible um and they did they worked
miracles with that ps2 hardware and then
from an emotional standpoint it was one
of the few games that ever made me cry
in my life and the only games that I
recall that made me cry out of the
Colossus the ending of Red Dead believe
it or not and journey journey made me
made me shed it here um so the story
around it to me I mean founded before
the story the thing that makes this game
so special is the the scale that it
brings to gaming like I had never seen
anything in gaming to this point that
presented scale this way it really made
you feel tiny in comparison to these
beasts that you were hunting and so the
story around that is what made it kind
of a very powerful and emotional thing
where it's like you know you're just a
quick overview of the story without
spoiling anything shallow the Colossus
is basically about this guy named wander
isn't his name is wander um and his
horse agro and he goes to this temple he
goes to this temple to try to save the
life of a woman that he cares for deeply
that's kind of everything that you
that's all they give you a terms of
exposition um so he takes you to this
temple but in order for her to get
healed he has to slay these colossi they
don't give him any rhyme or reason they
just say this is what you need to do to
get what you need um so he blindly goes
out on this quest to save this person he
cares for so the story handles like you
know
themes of sacrifice and what you would
do for someone that you love and the
consequences of doing that stuff blindly
without seeing what what what other
havoc you're causing around you so it's
it's a fantastic story it's one of those
games that nefeli of games that I feel
this way about that should always be
brought forward in generation so that
people that didn't experience it can
come back to it or can experience it for
the first time in a different light um
and with this remake of side of the
classes like Blue Point games hit it out
of the park like they took the essence
of that game and they didn't change that
at all but they just made the most
beautiful remake I've ever seen of any
game that we've seen remasters for we've
seen like you know high res texture
packs added to games this thing is
absolutely gorgeous and I think you know
they retain they retain the spirit of
the game in such a way that I think
everybody should experience this game um
on the technical from the technical
standpoint um there's some things that
are still wonky that they kind of
slavishly stuck to how the game played
on they made some improvements in terms
of the jump button and the grab button
which were in awkward places on the
PlayStation 2 so they made it you know
they did things properly for from what
we know as what should be the jump
button in this day and age which is the
X button and the aim or the a button on
on Xbox so things like that to make the
controls feel better but when I said
they slavishly sort of stuck to the to
the how the game was like the climbing
mechanics when you're climbing anything
except colossi it's still wonky like you
just like jumping from place to place
it's not it's not exactly it's still
kind of wonky and I wish they kind of it
would have smooth that stuff out but
that said I mean to me the game the
game's an all-time classic and it's this
is the best way to play it absolutely
best way to play it um I started playing
it I started playing for the first time
yesterday
I never played it I really want to hear
you
you know because I listen to it already
week ahead I played it in I will said
the graphics are amazing they think
they're absolutely like I had seen the
original and I had seen the ps3
remasters right and this this is it
looks amazing it really is
the only thing about it is you do feel
the age in its design but like for a
remaster that you that's a real question
it because we had this discussion last
night about remasters vs. roommate and
everyone's supremely well this is being
a remake I'm like kinda I guess it's
kind of laterally but it's it's yes the
graphics are a lot better but they did
keep a lot of the original intention
like if it was a remake oh yeah here's
an example when Bioshock collection came
out and they redid Bioshock 1 that is a
remastered no matter like they yeah they
redid they did it from the ground up to
make it everything looks so much better
like my res kept everything but they did
all this to make everything look better
that is true but at the same time what
they did was they didn't change anything
else about the game the game was the
same all the way through the control
scheme how everything played you still
wasting your time with all that the
camera and all that goes enough and it
that is it's a remaster because they
kept the original intention team a
remake is like we're redoing the whole
thing it's kind of like um like we're
watching a movie like there's a remake
that we'll redo it shot-for-shot and
then there's a like a really a remake
that will do it as okay we're taking the
same premise but changing the story yep
and that's kind of the difference I look
at it as yeah I just don't understand
why we keep talking about remakes versus
remasters like does this community ever
move on no we don't really stay right
here where we're comfortable remake
versus remaster my thing is this this
was built from the ground up they kept
they kept the entire I said the
integrity of what the game was a
and they slaves we stuck to that because
she says for me certain games like if
you change too much of it like they
literally like they change they didn't
change camera angles and stuff like that
because then it messes with the
intention of the game on an emotional
level right so when you do that then you
have to rework everything in that regard
so and again it depends on how much
leeway they were given like they were
like all right build it from the ground
up to be aesthetically beautiful but the
game proper has to feel the same and
that's that's that's a tough thing to
say so it's me when the assets are
completely new you're remaking that I
understand what you mean like from from
from a gameplay premise that it's it's
nothing new lady they had the template
already but I mean when you look at
Bioshock and stuff like that that's a
remaster do you just you're taking old
assets there were probably high
resolution assets to begin with you
didn't have the you didn't have the
horsepower to push those assets and
you're bringing them up and putting them
on machines that can handle them better
I think a real amount of shock they
remade it but if I were considered
classify them a remake is something that
is what I'm looking for has the exact
same content in the game and a rematch
no no Bri Master has the exact same
concept the game it's been redone to you
know to standards and a remake is
something like mmm let them vote
entirely from reboots I consider a
remake of yeah yeah like you reboot the
franchise in a totally different
direction let's say it's spider-man they
remade spider-man over from the last
Amazing Spiderman and you got the
homecoming right you know let's say if
they did a remake they would've did the
same exact same four scenes not for that
but just gave it HDR and up the graphics
and the resolution yeah yeah um I
understand
I want to anchor to talk about the horse
yeah god awful
mechanics are awful the horse-riding
mechanics are another thing that is like
really like with all the all the great
horse riding mechanics we have in red
dad and like well you have to be that
complicated either that's the thing like
yeah hold down X instead of triangle
it's bad look and they say and there's
no reason for it like I don't think by
changing that you affect the integrity
of the game at all I think little things
like that it's like yeah I a lot of
times I prefer not to ride him I like
I'll ride him I'll ride the horse for
the general area have to go to and then
I'll just walk because he's gonna follow
you anyway yeah it's just stuff like
that it doesn't make sense with with the
care that they gave to the rest of the
game um so yeah you know what's great
about it though is again it brings it it
brings it to a new generation of people
who haven't played the game and just on
aesthetics alone they're gonna see it
that way what is this I gotta play this
you know and it if they can do that with
games like you know give give Metal Gear
Solid to Blue Point let them remake that
you know anything that's considered an
all-time classic I think you it's kind
of on the gaming community to bring that
stuff forward so that you you presented
to newer newer generations so they don't
forget like where this stuff came from
but well this is the reason why we are
afraid of the new Sony head this is the
reason right right because man right and
we don't feel that he's gonna put in the
labor love it's as fast you honestly
think that this game is going to make as
much money as Shadow of the Colossus the
first one I don't know it's been a dry
this is a dry January for exclusives
Orange February so I mean hey was
nothing else right now I know the
Monster Hunter but even then like you
yet all the height for like the last 12
years so we've had time I'm picking the
game up you know um because somebody was
bloviating it to the point that they
almost forgot
they were telling the world that the ACR
was the greatest HDR they'd ever seen I
said that's impossible with only two
light sources and three shades of colors
but um I feel you I said maybe break
that down let me break that down so you
see why you know always bring we always
come from different point of views when
it comes to the tech stuff so I'll break
that down right I read your statement I
think it is the best implementation of
HDR right so this is what this is what
we have to think about when we talk
about HD all right 80 are the two main
components of HDR our wide color gamut
right 10-bit color twelve bit color a
mansion of the color gamut right and at
what I consider to be more important at
this point in time at this point in time
you just said well you consider right
right but I'm gonna tell you why I'm
gonna tell you why because the
subjective right now just when you put
you into it it just became subjective
right and I'm going to show you how my
opinions are not coming from just those
Saab is right about that too because the
HDR does make a huge difference oh yeah
I had not turned on the HDR port for my
TV at that time on my my playstation so
I I had never turned it on at that point
so I started playing it I was uh and I
looked at the after the very beginning
says turn on HDR and I was like okay
cool I'm gonna turn on the HDR it's
gonna be dope and it said you're a TV is
not HDR compatible I was like excuse me
so I played a little bit of the game so
I was like okay yeah it's really good so
I went and um I turned it off and put it
back up after turning on the HDR on the
port on my TV right and it was night and
day like crazy right rap yeah yes
nightly day no anchor do I do you know
what the the actual fight is do you know
what the fight is yet because see I
gotta set it up for the crowd to
understand it
we say you can know where summer is
coming from so y'all don't get swayed by
what he's about to do now what he's
about to tell you yeah yeah yeah fact
it's true didn't know this is true this
is true these are facts right and what
he's trying to tell you is that the HDR
is the best implementation of HDR and
from his standpoint like he said from
his standpoint and in a game right so
what he's saying is that this shadow of
Colossus is the best HDR and my argument
to that I said no sir no sir
you had a Gears of War 4 that was made
from the ground up with HDR built for
that right and I said um I believe this
is my exact words that's great for
PlayStation that's great for them that
that is the best HD off of them but you
said in a game and I believe that my
statement was that gives a war for HDR
is king right and I'm gonna explain to
you why I think that's not true
I'm still standing my license right so
let's explain right like I said at this
point in time I feel that peak
brightness and its relation to absolute
black is more important to HDR than wide
color gamut why do I say that right at
this point wide color gamut 10-bit color
these games that we're playing now are
still mastered an 8-bit the games that
we're doing are master it bit the movies
that were watching even 4k movies are
mastered an 8-bit so what what art
10-bit HDR is doing is just creating a
smoother gradation from color to color
it's not increasing the color damage so
much as it's just ink it's just
smoothing it out and it's an obvious
change you see it because when you put
something in 8-bit let's say Assassin's
Creed origins if you look at that in
8-bit you'll see very defined colors and
you see very like rough places where the
color ships from one to another
now you switch the 10 bit and that
gradation is much smoother giving it a
much more realistic look right but like
I'm like I was saying about the color
we're not at the place it with the color
that it should be
like you still have if you look at dolby
vision dolby vision is superior to ACR
ten but the problem is that because of
the licensing stuff not everyone uses it
so my thing is for color to be to be
where it needs to be in HDR we need to
look at the HDR 10 plus a standard
that's coming and need to be in terms of
color so let's go let's get into the
inter contrast and wise black and white
and that to me is more important when
you look at a game like Shadow the
Colossus shadow the Colossus it's it has
a very muted color palette it has like
four colors like but when you look at
the HDR implementation in the darkest
scenes and the lightest scenes
especially when you're literally
fighting a Colossus when you're
literally in the shadow but Colossus
I've never seen a game do that because
that has to account for a few things the
light sourcing in that area where you're
fighting the Colossus right and how that
light plays off of you wherever you may
be in the vicinity of that Club is use
the world right right right
alright so my question to you how many
light sources do you think was used at
that one particular moment that you're
talking about it this point when you're
fighting a colossi multiple lights work
yes multiple harmony number how many all
right so two to three right max I'm
gonna let you walk wait max 3 right
let's do this alright okay so you have
to run around this area in real time and
that light has to account for how it
hits you in real time how it hits you
how it hits the Colossus how the shadow
the qalaat the saddle that the Colossus
cast cast it on you this is all real
time right so right no everything is
rendered in real time but gears
is right word or super moving from one
place to another place those like is
what I would like for you to do is argue
your game right right
and then I will argue my game I'm gonna
give you the stats for my game you give
me this asking us you said three light
sources beautiful shadows real-time
right right HDR we don't abort a crowd
we want the crowd to give so let me tell
you why gears in that regard is inferior
gears of the corridor shooter regardless
of everything being the gr is inferior
my talking about the game gears and a
braggart is inferior from a technical
standpoint because the light sourcing is
only coming from one direction and oh my
god we're not really arguing about
something that you care about
but this HDR whole thing is something
that everybody in this chat has been
talking about tweeting about and
reporting about back and forth through
everyone now I have more than five to
six people on my side when I say this
whole thing gears has more than six and
I'm going to limit it to six so it has
doubled the amount of light sources that
you're talking about right okay let's go
to the part where you said said corridor
shooter so you're trying to say that
everything is fixed at this one point in
time mm-hmm but the best implementation
of HDR and when I'm telling you how
light realistically bounces with the eye
how light plays with the eye but if you
want to bring up the actual definition
of it is how we realistically see like
right know how we realistic how we see
reenlist i we saw how we realistically
see light right how is realistically see
the world in life right how we how we
guess you know we perceive like we are
we perceive our we realistically we look
at something
we say oh my god that [ __ ] looks really
realistic when it comes to how they're
portraying the light source right go
ahead you would say so
go go ahead okay stroke no the reason
why gear is a superior in the gears is
King is because they are using we got a
gun record so you are seeing that our
gears is king correct yes okay then
that's all I needed to know continued
the gears shifts on that game okay
continue yeah yeah actually amazed off
in the regard of HDR yes that's exactly
the same that's why I'm saying we just
needed the whole region of the tap of
court we needed that we need that
quotation or it can continue okay thank
you you write that down
alright so um the ACR that is being used
inside shadow of the colossus is the two
colors that they're using the two colors
the the tenth of green and the black
well we're not going to do in black will
give you yellow the tenth of green cuz
it's like a puke green that they use in
a vomit yellow right alright so now you
say that how many colors do you feel
like gears is using all the colors in
the color gamut that you talked about
what's not you don't think they using
more colors than the shadow of the
classes you said using all the colors
you said using more colors more colors I
mean the suite the digital out there
that has more colors in the volumetric
fog and a light source and bouncing off
the volumetric fog but tell you then my
argument was that the color is not as
important at this point like I know how
many colors they use these games use all
the colors of the wind we gotta move on
this
anyway we got to talk about hurry up
Lord King and I let's leave you with
this will agree to disagree on this
stuff until we both go to the grave
because we've always been for you I
would say Lord King has always been
about like he'll get achieve me in his
house right
whatever that TV provides as like a new
thing he's gonna use it no matter what
and I am that stickler for like you know
classic picture quality that that's the
dismissal is to you right now I want you
to understand that this man is lying to
you know the reason why he's lying to
you is because and this is gonna end the
argument the primarily yeah where did it
come from came from you right all the
time I just get up the new latest
greatest whatever that is but the
Pioneer League we're gonna say that that
is probably the best television that has
been created to be honest with you yes
beautiful right now
don't tell me that I get a TV and I put
all those specs on because I don't
because I didn't put it on downstairs
because you have to actually take it off
um when you watching certain things what
I'm explaining it to you is my q9 which
is the top part of my television when it
comes to HDR besides that um the old LED
bang amount for $25,000 one that I can't
afford that television will show you and
I said we can come we can do it live we
can have everybody see we can have
cameras set up we can do anything that
you would like to do so you can sit
there and see from this perspective I
want you to come on I want you to come
in I want you to touch the TV I want you
to put it to whatever you want to put it
to so
that way you can actually say yeah he's
right and I can say you're wrong people
without tech Doug all right real quick
for me the RPG royal the deacon of
Dreams the Sherpa of swagger Lord addict
do you have any thoughts about Shadow of
the Colossus Oh what were you saying no
a shadow the Colossus I think people you
know they take this remake and remaster
thing a little bit too seriously well I
keep seeing people arguing over that
over you know the remake remaster thing
and I'm like I mean it looks like a cool
game last time I checked you know I do
understand why they review these things
what clearly would have went good what
that game came out like 10 years ago
shadow cause I mean little be honest
here reviewing standards have changed in
10 years I do think every game that
comes out needs to be reviewed because
first office by different people now
unless you know who whatever these
outlets you know they let the same
person review it 10 years ago they
probably need to be like go hey you know
it's whatever when it comes to it it's
like am I gonna get it see how it goes
is up I have Monster Hunter Monster
Hunter Monster then the side of Monster
Hunter and then maybe I can get some
shadow Colossus after more Monster
Hunters so that's what my schedule is
right now because eventually means oh
look another Kane came out that I
actually got to purchase yes my initial
reaction was like I don't know if I want
to get Far Cry now I'm like that looking
pretty hot now cry and shadow is gonna
go right back in the shadows alright oh
there will be a kingdom hard session you
guys wait to them actually
that's the next little thing here so
room your topic for the afternoon here
what's your contribution this week hit
the lawyer didn't like I see apparently
Kingdom Hearts had some updates as
announced at their last event and uh you
know they've pretty much on the low-key
guaranteed I say uh a release date at e3
now part of me feels like they did and
they did low-key say it was coming out
this year to light you know there's
things kind of nothing's been confirmed
but pardon me feels like that's not the
case I feel like what's gonna happen is
we get to e3 and they're gonna announce
this coming out next year but I think
even if it comes out next year I'm okay
as long as I get a release date like I
don't really know be happy with a
release date well I'm not I don't want
to get to e3 they show us another
trailer and don't give us a release date
like I'm not okay with that
like I want a lock Tate they keep saying
coming 2018 unless that means like the
release date is coming games say they're
coming out in a certain time frame and
it gets pushed back especially games
that come out in the the holidays of
that year there's a good chance at least
one or two of them are getting pushed
back to the beginning of the night
especially this year with Red Dead
coming out at the end of the year it was
coming out anyway it was like no as long
as that game don't come out like a week
before yeah if it came out a week before
I think it would be fine but they need
at least have two weeks after right dead
I'm not even buying it doesn't like that
but you know like two weeks a good thing
about it weeks after that game I looked
at Kingdom Hearts and I mean this looks
like it's like the most they've shown us
in what years
I don't remember anything other than
remote with it well other than the Toy
Story thing but they showed off a lot in
this one they showed off like a Little
Mermaid summon they showed off a monster
they showed like it well I disagree
about that I think it looks like trash
it looks good what are you talking about
like when they showed off this game's
gonna look exactly like it does how
they're presenting it because it's not
going well I expected it to look like
the e3 2013 trailer you know five years
ago before developments that release a
decent so is that what you're telling me
you expect look like the game that they
starred the trailer they showed you
before the game even started developing
I expect this looks like a 2018
anchorman is confirmed but the problem
with that addict is as they showed it to
you as game played like this is a long
time ago and they showed it to you as
gameplay so yeah it was a vertical slice
and there's like five years to get that
right there they were find that vertical
slice to perfection so that's what you
expected because it was gameplay
everyone like everyone expects what uh
what the division to come out would it
look like
the widow no what kind of looked like
would it not you thought you what you
want to know how I know this they got
downgraded with their original vision
was look at the fur on Sully the fur on
Sully in the Kingdom Hearts trailer
looks worse than the technical
innovation you can't get that he's
alright for trash I mean it's whatever
it is betters fallout that that's
confirmed
the Toy Story right now and the Toy
Story looks like the Toy Story I mean -
a little bit of the lights or singing
and shading but I mean it looks really
great I can't I don't see where the game
looks bad at it looks in the forum so
I'm looking at the forest aisle
everybody look at the photo Sully you
see the farro Sully and it it looks
really good I mean for a game what did
you want it to look like that guy
monsters go look at Monsters Inc the
movie from why are you comparing two
entirely different forms of
entertainment first off second off first
off first off you can't even sit there
okay yeah that is a good point you can't
compare them because they're completely
that likes a section of the game is that
movie is in the game this game is the
movie bigger in game in terms of saw a
file size anchorman whoa amazing it'd be
different if you said oh I don't you
know I don't like what I see that would
be different but you see you're trying
to say it looks horrible when you
support fallout 4 what looks like
fallout 3 of a filter on come on anchor
come on that's it you was just really
trolling right there because I mean that
looks it looks way better than I thought
and we're not even looking at how it's
gonna look on the X like this yeah you
notice my playstation base or something
right oh my god look at this
you gonna get this game I have a wedding
new Kingdom Hearts games that I'm
actually gonna get this game well I
don't kink Cavazos gonna get the game
regardless so I'm gonna play him
I haven't played anything the Hearts
game shadow death stinger you would have
got a timeout for that statement no this
really looks what this looks better than
I thought it's way better than that crap
that you showed before now if you
thought all for that crap did they show
before it was reason to be concerned but
this actually looks really good it's a
really good looking game Wow go look at
the IG in comparison from fallout 4 and
fallout 3 and then come back to me and
keep in mind there's a game between
fallout 4 and fallout 3 called fallout
new vegas there were certain sections
that look better than 4 we're not
talking about that you guys are damage
controlling the way it looks saying it's
bigger it is bigger facts but anchorman
wasn't saying - based on how the size of
the game he was saying that fallout 4
looks better than Kingdom Hearts 3 I
never said that who brought up fallout
first here ok how many times he said
follow-up form it beats every
expectation he had would that not
include graphics oh yeah this is Baby
Doe that's his like that's his that I
love a halo 5 anything that anybody says
negative about the Ganic and you know
eat buttcrack for all I care
so stay follow for did meet all my
expectations but they also didn't bait
me for five years with the trailer oh my
god I gave you supposed to be I'm
curious
I gave you my intro here so you got the
rim
I waited for you to get here I didn't
you get you get to watch we won't do it
again King what's your topic for the
week oh my god so listen guys we have a
new player in this gaming space of ours
and it's not really a new player it's
actually our old player and if you have
a cell phone you will know who this
player is because 9 times out of 10 you
don't shopped at his store this is your
good pal Google what did you say Google
yes yes I guess say Google remember um
Google is probably one of the largest
companies in the world when it comes to
your mobile space right and being a
facilitate you purchasing games through
the Google Play Store they set out um
what was that uh Lord sovereign when
they did a couple of towns with fiber
wire right why the wire
you're good
sorry yeah it went as far as some window
I think Minnesota got it it has the East
Coast though it still started with
whatever this fire
why're out right and they weren't they
wanted to put it in everybody's homes
and everybody got high-speed Internet
through Google so I know a lot of people
are saying wow I never heard of that
yeah but now what Google is doing
because Phil Harrison used to work for
Microsoft and he used to work for Sony
right and he was in key positions during
their growth in the gaming space now he
is at Google in their gaming space and
it's called Yeti and I forgot the other
code name for the system now they're
gonna be making the controller in-house
sort of how steam controllers were those
controllers really didn't take off they
would revert it right back to a
Microsoft controller but um I believe
this controller because they show the
schematic of it it's built more like a
Microsoft controller they understand
that that format actually works and the
system is going to be like a chromecast
type of system because they're going to
stream all the stuff now this takes it
back to Lord sovereigns implantation of
the cloud all over all around us and his
expertise and knowing exactly how the
cloud will be used here so this topic is
actually a two-way topic with sovereign
and I because we talked about it um I
want you know sovereign to explain to
you how they're gonna use the cloud as
far as getting the games to us travel I
think with these guys the thing with
Google that we have to remember is that
they they've seen two mistakes of past
companies trying to jump into this right
um you know we talked about before what
on life they made a lot of promises that
they were didn't have the infrastructure
to keep and you know they dislike your
they have the time and money to be able
to improve on the the cloud gaming same
with a PlayStation now PlayStation now
it's just starting to get some
PlayStation 4 games onto the service but
it's very difficult to be able to stream
stream those games in a way that's
playable and acceptable to core gamers
it's just it's just not something that's
there yet especially when you talk about
the online infrastructure
entire country like not everybody has a
bandwidth available for that stuff to
work properly as intended
now Google's been really quiet over this
time they haven't really done much in
that space and the assumption has been
is that because they've been looking at
the mistakes of these other companies
and working on something better um and
that's really interesting to me like I
said like my topic a couple of weeks ago
with the shadow cloud-based service
obviously people haven't stopped working
on this stuff obviously we talked about
how it was kind of the butt of a lot of
jokes especially with PlayStation now
but this stuff they see value in this
and not necessarily even as as the
pillar of your gaming of your gaming
[Music]
implementation but maybe even it's just
a side thing that allows people to have
enough of a quality experience where
it's viable to sell this stuff as a
service um so the cool thing about
Google and how they they work this is
that they have a few different ways they
can they can implement this stuff first
we don't know what their tech is because
their tech is probably completely
different something they worked out from
the ground up so they're active there
you've been considering doing this stuff
is exciting for what they have in the
pipeline that they haven't showed us
right but they have some advantages as
opposed to other people have tried to do
this in a few key areas first of all
they have chromecast um they're gonna
have a set-top box that's associated
with this I think they just call it Yeti
as well I think the whole project is
called yes Yeti is Yeti is the Box the
controller is called something else I
think it's called Lugo right right right
so the thing with that is that they have
their plan is to allow you to purchase
this if you want but also to implement
it through chromecast plenty of people
have chromecast so it's it's something
again that's it's gonna be an ease of
use type of thing right so first thing
is that in terms of their OS they're
probably it would make sense for them to
run Android TV because they're they make
it they make it you're you're sort of
set top box replacement right you don't
need a Roku stick after that you need
the Apple TV after that you don't
and again chromecast oh right
has all this stuff in there so that's
that's something that they can do to
sort of kind of push it into homes that
that that that already have this stuff
in them um another thing another thing
is allowing you to sort of download some
games not necessarily all of them again
it's it allow you kind of to walk the
line between pure streaming and
downloadable stuff whereas something
like game passes only downloads where
not everybody again has the bandwidth to
be able to do that so you need just by
giving people more options it and
hopefully had a good price point it's
something that's attractive to people
all right so you believe there's gonna
be a hybrid combo type of streaming
downloaded unless they bring something
to the table that nobody has seen and
just boost bandwidth threefold I don't
think right now it's it's gonna be able
just to push you know modern games
through bandwidth I just don't think so
again but well shadow shadow shadow was
very impressive you know based on what
Richard Ledbetter said that stuff is
impressive so if Google's been mum and
hasn't said anything who's to say that
whatever they have in the works isn't
more impressive so that's then you so
this is what we bring to the to the
lords this Sunday and this topic and how
do we feel about Google getting into
gaming do we feel like it's going to be
Apple gaming or Philips gaming or will
they be to the next Sony because
remember Sony was laughed and scoffed at
before they even got this system off the
ground my question to the table is how
do we feel about Google in our space and
do we think that they're gonna be viable
that's a that's a good question actually
because I is Google viable
yes by the very nature of Google
existing anything they put themselves
behind will be viable mm-hm they will
find a way to market that thing they
will get it into people's homes whether
they like it or not they will find a way
but the only thing about it though is
will the gaming community jump on
at least as far as how we're set up here
we're like well people from Sony or
Microsoft like no the loyal fans move
over to Google I have no idea I really
don't know question what wouldn't it be
like this great way like let's say
you're walking home right and let's say
it is like a hybrid thing like a lower
sovereign the same and you're walking
home you have your phone and you go into
Google playing you downloaded gear into
your phone and it's already at your
house yeah yeah that's that impossible
I mean it's yo all your goo can I kind
of devices are connected anyway
something like it's all there I think
the real question is just whether or not
the the hardcore will adopt it that that
is the the real thing because they
people will clearly jump on board
just cuz new word it's Google but it's
whether or not people will actually jump
on and say this is a valid replacement
to my system because the only thing I'm
not sure Google will do is actually have
like be a publisher and publish their
own games as much as it is they're going
to be like a competitor to steam or
something like that right I think
they're gonna go pristine but they're
gonna go specifically after the steam
market and say hey we're Google your
games follow you everywhere you're
already using Google Chrome it's already
there like I just think I think do we
see this as steam knowingness and said
that's what the entertainment of the
mark the soft stuff was coming from oh
maybe I think that's that's the only
other option yeah if you're gonna go
against Google you gotta have a real
good product you gotta have got a good
will and you gotta have money back in
yourself stay alive yeah yup monies well
that would be interesting though addict
how do you feel about the topic are you
doing about this Google thing yeah I
mean I don't care do you play any games
on your phone like candy crush or
something like that no cookie Jam
it's exclusive to the new google it if
if freedom experienced king over here
won't buy that [ __ ] you'll have to show
me they must see it really will have to
knock my side so I spent $600 on a lot
of consoles in this time guys seriously
and three do I just talked about it the
other day was top of the list but when
they did show me something they showed
me why my $600 is being spent okay if
these guys can show me why my $600 is
being spent I'll be the first one online
but Google I'm not even a lot of you
honest they're gonna have regardless
they got money they do there's no
denying that but we're in an industry to
where people are they willing to invest
in the amount it would it's not like
Microsoft you know Microsoft needs to to
catch up or you know get a little bit
more the install base these people need
to get in the industry period and that's
gonna cost ya allah ya honey
photographer amazon coming in that was
the thing we did now it's gonna be
google looks like it might come before
them what should be apples all is in the
gaming space right now yeah they are no
you got names right now
they have lumberyard oh yeah there have
some some weak divisions I mean because
my kids have the Amazon um with the
controller and the Amazon play and and
they watch their movies and they go to
the game and section and they actually
play it's a mild form of streaming it's
a mild form but it's it's not as big as
Google as making this sound and if when
you're in the New York Times and when
you're in business weekly and
information is being let out because
Google doesn't let anything out when
information is being let out they're
letting you know that's quiet before the
storm and the storm is coming I and you
start to look at stuff in the wild and
you start to see people positioning
narrow their movement once a Nintendo
said they're going into a streaming type
of service type of thing again for
service type of thing you don't
understand they know business guys know
where the market is going and you know
they pretty much lead by what's out
there and we've noticed that game paths
has been successful PlayStation now has
been successful to some extent and other
gaming services as far as steam has been
highly successful on the PC front you
understand so why not let another big
company get their hands in this pot and
pull back money and I think Google is
going to dig their hands in this pot I
just don't know what form it has to it
has to be something it's vastly
different to what's out there again
again I don't think that I don't care
the quality of that third console I
don't think the the market can support
another regular console in homes it just
would it like you know if Nintendo had
come out with the switch in in a normal
console form in the house I don't think
it'd be nearly as except successful so I
think they definitely it has to come
from a different angle completely
different angle yeah and again with all
this investment in the cloud gaming
stuff they have to have something that's
vastly superior to what was out before
to even consider doing this sort of
stuff so um it's gonna be is gonna be in
this is one owning some superior
they just need to come out therefore
console and open the pay uh the the
piggy bank deep enough to get all kinds
a third-party [ __ ] exclusive oh yeah I
mean that the money matters you know at
this point I'm pretty sure that they
know they gonna have to put some real
money what do you guys think it would
require for them to come in let's pick
three third-party titles that's
reasonable that they would purchase for
exclusivity for like the whole game not
just time what would you fight it to be
already know Capcom is loose with the
legs so I think I think they'd straight
out by Nintendo here Microsoft couldn't
get them to do that deal there is no way
in hell
they probably Microsoft likely had a
budget though let's break the bank I
need you on that camera hopefully say
you will buy your each okay oh wait okay
so what's the time frame did I get for
this announcement and know something
this drastic okay it's if they enter by
Nintendo years no I give them 16 months
16 by 2020 seems fair that's two years
that's two years alright two years all
right so two years if they don't buy
them y'all eat right and if they do
bother them Beauty don't buy you a top
we're gonna have to take a step back
from this bed so whatever they're
building is a is a high-end console you
guys think that no it'll be like a Julia
I really will be like a Dooley about a
more beefy to be competing with the
PlayStation and Xbox but after days I
don't think so either I think the people
they need to be hitting up is they need
to hit Ubisoft up if they got a couple
good Ubisoft games in their back pocket
I think it'd be enough to jump but
they're gonna have to come out first
party as well they're gonna have to come
out with some first party stuff oh no
not a first party if I were them I would
try to get a big first party to a third
party title exclusive nothing like
really really big obviously something
that has whistle are looking for that
has a little bit of pool and then I
would start buying no I mean that's
these games that had a following but you
know they dropped off like arm you to
mercenaries if it's a brand new title I
don't think Google is gonna spend that
kind of money to get really good stuff
like I just don't mind that if they do
spend the money on there they're got to
spend the money on the research and
development for making the actual
console well they did that already I
mean that stuff is pretty much done we
just getting a small leak of it out so
what they're the controller the scheme
is pretty much done the system format
it's pretty much done listen I already
make home guys that's one of the reasons
I touch PlayStation exactly I feel you
and I feel the same way I just ordered a
new Playstation controller
like if they if they were trying to be
smart and they wanted to actually break
into the break into the gaming market
but do so out of getting budget like it
by platinum by focus Home Interactive
that won't buy newly those our studios
or cheap publishers where they could
that could work play like that of like
dressing up like complete dog garbage
and like making it look like an a-rated
game gonna have to do something even
make me purchased as they can't do it I
could not produce plans a purchase
platform I'm gonna laugh all the way to
not buy and they [ __ ] and buy you know
I'd rather I would rather go buy another
we you before I buy anything that they
would make if they bought platinum is
the first Mari studio so we are wrapping
up on this topic guys alright alright
alright
so last topic for the evening
one morning in the morning whatever it's
easy for Cognito who's not here so
Monster Hunter world came out about I'm
a beast
I got a I'm a beast so the monster what
our world came out and it has been they
like always I always ignore you do so
monster will came out and we are sitting
here at six million copies sold after
two weeks and there's been a lot of the
discussion going on around around the
board here about a monster hunter and
we'll use some anecdotal evidence real
quick kind of give you an idea I'm
sitting here on the Xbox taking a look
look at night so he see you
Rinne on his face ring listen he's gonna
regurgitate their number five on the top
play this game we're looking right now
at the top most our top paid less not
played look about the top people that
got the money best one on the list here
above pub G above Madden above EA Sports
above everything else on the most played
list let's take a look here I really
listen I can't tell you guys how much
sheep ISM is going on with this crappy
game I'm telling you is washed out you
can't join your friend and I know you
love the game I want you to be honest
how long did it take for me to join your
game me and you together yes we did
remember I was a hobby don't lie total
truth now we actually did you just join
my session we actually played a game no
we joined discussion you took me to an
arena oh yeah it did it did take a
minute no there ain't no denying that
the way that they decided to make this
like interactive co-op [ __ ] is why and
they need to be took out in the back
thank you oh let's shirt over that okay
all right
so this is that's my whole stance I'm
not even going to get into any of the
technical crap with this game that they
promoted the game with right they told
you so here's a phrase everybody can get
into this world
wait wait wait cuz I listen to you all
last night talk about it
I go on record and state that anchorman
talked to all that all that stuff on the
inner circle yesterday and did not once
say that he ain't killing these bosses
that me and gamble are carrying him
through this stuff okay hey I'm getting
two right now you didn't give me my
recognization you showed up late whose
fault is that
you are gonna think I was like you were
bad intro I'm not you know wasn't do
that one he's not the greatest at intros
and we all mix Cognito sorely missed see
you all next week
hope everything is well with the family
you know we needs to give us like the
gues intros one bob wad cuz we ain't
really got that long the topic at hand
though destiny to which is having an
event right now so the player base
should be up is now sitting at number 14
on the most played list you know behind
it
fallout 4 is right behind destiny 2 was
worse 20 years this elder is sitting
right on its door black ops 3 is above
plot as debuff destiny to rocket League
overwatch Madden Ark right one thing we
won't do it one thing we won't do in
this podcast is take a gun on my
Slean all right we're not gonna do that
that's it's all about iron Lords and
it's all about this destiny now maybe we
have a couple of missteps maybe the game
is not being played and I'm listening
I'm guilty of that right now cuz I've
been on this pub G very heavy alright
but we're not gonna sit here and blow
Veit this broken game that you can't
join your friends and everybody's
sitting here blowing bubbles up people's
butts talking about how fantastic it is
and you're sitting there holding your
breath off of what's wrong what's the
game you can take down a monster and get
a nice suit you look good in your suit
but I can't say cuz I can't join you I
don't like it but there's just one thing
that we've got to make very apparent
right now is to be carried by you he
probably was in such a yo listen we
spent a good 20 minutes remember I kept
saying I can't join while a cinematic is
in order what type of crop is thank you
Microsoft for giving me my money because
this is 2018 and I'm not settling for
this 2001 crap attic attic don't take
the bait just don't hurry his behind
when you do it just make sure when when
the list goes out for the friends that's
trying to join and they can't find
lobbies don't put them on your list
that's it I'm gonna have to inform all
of my all of my monster honor brethren
you know the other people that would
care you that you're a banned from being
carried for anything those people who
wasn't for me it doesn't matter that you
can't take back to cease when it comes
to Medi meet people like two years ago
that'll make sense I'm gonna have to
there's Samuel childhood we got to give
you no respect for the Lord that's
inside the chat I love your Esther
expose days I love the stuff that you
writes fantastic and remember you
acknowledge that this is your first
monster hunter game you have not put up
with this crap that I have put up with
sir I have put up with this crap awful
multiple system sir and I was looking
for this game to be the savior that they
claimed it to be and it is not that I
mean this is not the savior don't add to
it I had to put it down ahead to get rid
of it it is gone it is erase are you
turning to make that's kind of addict
don't let me get a me too anyway the
topic at hand is whether or not destiny
two can make a comeback after monster
hunter is pulling away a lot of these
people who have been wanting this night
this kind of grind this kind of this
kind of work that destiny to was not
able can they learn from monster hunter
world look I might never be learn how to
join a friends I could join you there's
gonna be more people playing destiny
than monster he's reaching here man you
know clouds in my game and all I needed
there one good deal seat away from
knocking you back into the box you
didn't tell me how many games that are
destiny to so you just told me that this
game is new kid on the block that showed
up that everybody is I'm so happy that
it's all Microsoft this year I'm gonna
purchase and I'm gonna take it I don't
care if you to take it good I don't care
you don't even get why you you don't
even
get half of the stuff that they got on
PlayStation ah no I'm not gonna do it
I'm gonna take that game get it out of
here right off the door dude the only
way I think destiny koutou can make a
comeback is if they're big taking King
kind of DLC was totally free oh shut up
they came out and did that they said oh
yeah
we got the return of the taken King free
this year like that that would be nice
you will want it to be free but you're
gonna pay for this you are the game
listen this is true and it doesn't
appeal to you but it appeal to I don't
know how many people purchase this game
and I'm pretty sure that you could pull
the numbers up like you'd be pulling
numbers out of the sky you got those six
million off the sky right why don't you
get total lifetime numbers of Destiny to
pull that out of the sky and let me know
what I'm pretty sure than half of it is
it let's tell me do they do we have a
peek three million players playing this
game at one time are they playing now
soft pop G unknown unknown franchise
specific numbers they said it was they
had record sales but didn't specific
sales we've ever had that's a record
sale right yeah so what they had
missteps but this game is a colossal
mistake alright so if they came out
dating they want why did they put that
game outdated a against destiny why
didn't they do that
listen Dan who would have sold you tell
me answers that question answer that
question an anchor is next to this ok
does they launch first they was ready
that was ready what's up what's up so
Capcom tom is the one with the speaking
east rockaway that game wasn't ready I
gave the same game we play
so why don't you release that broken
crap up against my broken crap and let's
see who broken crap would it not Wow I
definitely understand destiny wouldn't
knock them out with the ease of play and
joining your friends system is so
beautiful it is I can go right now and
you should wait to play around do
nothing
hey but you know what I can't even do
that inside that game I can't wait
around and do anything I was so happy
that day me an addict was getting a
chance to play I really just felt real
good
this is the chance is the greatest when
it comes to that co-op community like is
it co-op friendly no fun yes I
understand that but look you know is
it's like I said is it co-op accessible
to everyone is it make sense sometimes
no cuz at the beginning I was like what
do I do but once you figure it out
ask-ask anchorman it goes pretty easy
yeah you know it's really easy when
anchorman can just you know how it works
is you know you go to the board you post
it and everyone and conjoining on that
quest so you know what any command goes
and does his next story in me and gamble
can just do that whole story for a more
an anchorman does nothing that's how
that works
the thing about the thing about monster
hunter is is what you worry about is the
longevity like what like what's their
plan moving forward like destiny is a
living game right so obviously they're
gonna keep giving you stuff yeah well
but hopefully the plan is that they keep
improving upon stuff is gonna bring back
to hardcore I think they are doing stuff
to bring back to our core they had me
raising my eyebrows with the UH the
update they're doing on the raid but
it's not great functions and stuff that
I have a problem with I have a problem
with the raid itself so the location yes
no attic no I don't want anyone in this
chat to be confused with what anchor has
just done okay I don't want you to be
confused trying to get me and you to go
at it because he knew I was a big fan of
monster and your big lesson
but what he didn't understand this me
and you already play the game and he
already heard my grapes which said game
and it's well known as well documented
but he doesn't also understand that the
Love Dare right and we don't he don't
understand that the love we share with
destiny too and the such great times
that we had in that game in the destiny
space so that can't override that and
that's not gonna change that for some
reason we wanna 2018 lovefest brother
nobody's coming and smashing sorry I
just big dump in office Kingdom Hearts I
see what you were trying to do did you
see me just show Kingdom Hearts did you
see me just back my man walking through
that door sorry I'm sorry
anchor sorry we didn't catch different
different of what's a good word I'm
looking for we on the same train King
goes on the train above me and me
economy tow was on the same train this
year but now it's me King on the same
train and sovereign incognito are on the
same train like a sovereign is also
loving crap with that HBO stuff with
this Colossus understand man listen you
you and I'm talking about that game is
one taking King away from being
irrelevant and that's just the facts
that's the scary part about it because
it's already digitally downloaded into
everybody system and those people that
actually went on a purchase a disk it
really probably so it's a king near went
Bill Cosby right
he said I see what you're trying to do
understand that he fears it because he
got the ballistic beatdown with the
fallout I feel like fall out it's still
behind destiny he had to point that out
on the list they're still behind a dead
game right okay so you're getting your
day your game is deader all right if
that's the word all right so look at
this one DLC is going to come and crush
that game and the ease of use and
playing with your friends when I say I'm
in a nightfall and say hold on are
coming right now
because we're the party we're talking
now how do I do it I can't see it I
don't understand
no join my game and then maybe if I
haven't played this long enough you
could join so um understand the DLC is
coming the fear is in the room I could
smell it I smell it you smell it I smell
it
and when it's going down I'm going to
bite you into the game anchor and we're
gonna play a good game because you can
join me let me tell you something
they're right back in the mix baby won't
even know why increments trying to like
like put that monster on your banner he
ain't done nothing in the game let me
ask an actual question here so do you
guys that monster hunter with all the
success that has had in the West this
time out because to be honest it had it
hasn't had the success in the West
before this game do you think they make
changes to it to make it even more
appealing to Western gamers now that
it's seen this success and do you think
they really come for games like destiny
like in the future
to be fair well Monster Hunter isn't
that
once the hunter is a destiny it's a game
run to itself you have some dlc monsters
who have this it's not like what destiny
is at all but when you see there those
player base is moving over like you know
a lot of a move to flop G a lot of it
moved to Monster Hunter because the
grind in like that grind like the
minutiae of that grind do you see the
game view of monster hunter it's Massa
has been the same for a long time to
change that forever that'd be an
interesting thing to see what they do
with this game and to try to make it
even more popular they might mess it up
you know in the in the chat real quick
so now we go from it looks bad so now
you try to justify it because it's so de
long okay continue now they're gonna
change anything in Monster Hunter I
think they'll start changing some of the
aesthetics
you know bothering to actually like
lip-sync with the English language it's
very nice I think other than that I
think the core gameplay is fine I think
it's totally fine the way it is I think
it's not too hard to jump into but I
think it is the aesthetic changes to it
will be will be made for the Western
audience going forward I think it's kind
of like how Resident Evil change it up
significantly whether as an evil 7 and I
know they made it you know they needed
to would resume evil 7 which is a great
horror game within itself
I thought it was I think that the people
ran away from Resident Evil so much that
there wasn't willing to give 7 a try to
be honest with you I think they broke
that that franchise and 7 and 7 apart
from the first-person perspective when
you really get in there it's a residual
game it isn't yeah what's different from
other rebel games in terms of systems
and without it's just a first-person it
so it the flow of the game is different
but it's is definitely receive ok
so I mean it's gonna be I don't know
that they would be willing it's been so
it's been so successful for so long
I don't know that they're gonna continue
to they would maybe some more like a
hobby like improvements
they're printing money with this thing
you know they print their money with it
on a desk they print the money with it
on a switch they print the money with it
on the PlayStation on the Xbox now we
got the game here and they notice okay
finally there's a audience over here
that wants this cuz you know you
actually saw this game over there and
maybe you didn't want to buy a 3ds and
sitting in a train station playing it
all on the bus or whatever okay that's
fine
you got on your big console and it's
nice I'm not taking anything away from
that aspect of it if you're a new player
and I'm pretty sure there's a lot of new
players I'm pretty sure at least two to
three million of the players purchase in
this game are new players so you don't
know what somebody like myself has been
through with this game and won't
tolerate right because I went in went
into the game looking for something very
specific any mr. mark on that thing
saying that just agitated the whole
thing alright it was like a hair bump on
your face if you don't pull it out
you're gonna get a nasty bump right so
it was a nasty bump and I just had to go
get it removed it was disgusting um do I
think they fix a certain things for us
yes
but fundamentally on a user interface
it's broken
okay they can send as many patches as
they want to the game the dynamic and
how you join and it's fundamental to the
game structure it's broken so questions
only fix that that's that they just stay
just patch that you able to find lobbies
to play with people that's not my
problem
hmm he's not an admission system that's
what he doesn't like right here you
understand see the problem with anger
right now is he understands am i great
hey guys this is your first monster hunt
the game yes technically second I have
played the one that came on the way they
goes three okay yeah but yeah I did not
fight him play that serious no really
play seriously right so technically this
is your
one that you dove in that you made armor
and you're having a good time in right
that's great
hello yes that's correct
okay so now it's saying this what's the
majority of your time using it a hundred
percent as your barometer
what's the majority of your time that
you spend alone in that game playing it
for me maybe sixty percent right so more
than often yeah so more than half by
yourself right now destiny with himself
it's made up in the manner that you play
eighty percent with people and 20
percent by yourself see my mind's a
little bit different a monster or not
probably but in eighty percent with
other people in twenty by myself right
yeah for me though I'm grinding the same
missions over and over and over again
for materials that's what I've been
doing so learning about that in destiny
mmm-hmm well the only thing is at least
these materials are something I can
actually control and it's not a complete
RNG system right to get if you kill
right he knows if he kills certain
amount of monsters he's gonna get
certain amount of materials to do
exactly what he wanted like that bowl
that you wanted to get that cow without
if he kills a certain amount of monsters
if he lets drink a certain amount of
monsters okay alright so now that we got
that out the way and we understand that
the game is a nice phenomena is not
really a phenomena it's just these guys
are thirsty for they put it out in a
month with nothing was happening
put it up head-to-head against something
let's see what really is on the tables
your balls is really on the table I
don't think so
I don't think the testicles of this game
is big enough to go against the weakest
of our franchises I don't think it'll
come out on a day or two K I know it
won't come out on a day of madam don't
even talk about red death it just came
out on a Down month now all we are is
one good game to come out and push that
right to the side
simple topic all right so I think that
rounds out our topics but yeah - because
I do think what the topic expected that
to go completely different than it did
my my original question was is there
anything destiny - can learn from well
monster hunter world nothing that they
didn't know already they already know
that people want the grind back people
want to feel like what they're doing is
special and you know is there anything
monster can learn from destiny play with
somebody's real quick will pose the
final poll question
King Henry gotcha you say hey King let
them know where they can find you I go
last again why you keep putting me first
hey listen guys check it out I got four
large t shirts left
get at me hit me in the DMS on Twitter I
know if you're a fan of the podcast you
know our Twitter um and you should be
following us on Twitter like you should
be following an addict you should be
following anchor you should be following
everyone from the TIC Network um so just
get out me hemming the DMS the store
should be up the store will be up by
Friday of this week in time for your
Black Panther you can wear it Lord man I
just see if I can overlay ship of T so
you get into that movie theater you look
all that types are good with the Lord on
your chest that'll be fantastic for me
um
so hit me up guys and next guy see I
used to this alright thanks for everyone
coming out definitely follow me on
Twitter and you know it's a pleasure
being on this again every week goes by
and you know I just wanted the last
thing you guys here is a for me as a I
carried anchorman through monster honor
okay continue guys you can find me on on
PSN and xbox live at BX sovereign and on
Twitter Lord saw IOP shout out to Burt
Jonathan kognito and the family
condolences to the family I hope you
guys well and look forward to having you
back next week
shout out to anchor for coming in and
babysitting us this is the worst
babysitter ever he was having a spit
fight so I'm a Crabby - you guys fight
finally over here on the inner circle
network as usual doing my usual thing
tick podcast on Saturdays at 10 o'clock
like multiverse at 8 on Mondays and go
on the occasional sonication but yes for
the final question you know monster
under the other time alright so the poll
question for next week which will put
will get that on the twitter account
officially do you think the Monster
Hunter franchise will keep the Western
audience going forward whether your
options are gonna be yes yes West is
best no East is beast and lastly who can
I just want fallout 5 Oh what oh my god
this is a terrible you know I should
have known it was a terrible toll when I
did see a post it in the chat
[Laughter]
all right guys husband episode 50 the
iron list podcast and we slow-danced
next key guys pop G we are I'm jumping
on right now
alright and we're out